[Musique]
certains fournisseurs sans fil n'aime
pas quand vous les sortez de leur zone
de confort par exemple si vous allez au
chalet que vous travaillez loin de chez
vous parce que sans vous en rendre
compte vous sortez peut-être de la zone
desservie par votre fournisseur sans fil
et vous est alors pris en charge par les
antennes d'un autre fournisseur c'est ce
qu'on appelle un réseau partenaires les
fournisseurs se rendent de petits
services comme ça si tu prends mes
clients je vais prendre les tiens mais
attention si vous utiliser davantage le
réseau partenaires parce que vous êtes
souvent loin de chez vous le réseau
partenaire est pas mal moins disposés à
rendre service et pour vous ça peut
vouloir dire qu'après quelques mois et
quelques avertissements par texto vous
perdez votre accès à l'autre réseau
si c'est votre cas vous devez consommer
moins chez le partenaire est plus chez
vous activez le mode de données réduite
quand vous êtes au chalet servez vous du
wise as il y en a où vous vous trouvez
pour le travail ou encore changer de
fournisseur
passés le mot
[Musique]
oh